what is going on everybody and welcome
to part three of our tensor flow object
detection API tutorials series in this
video and the subsequent few videos
we're going to be covering how to track
a custom object whatever object we could
possibly want with this API so using the
API and the pre trained models and all
that it's actually super simple as you
saw in the first two videos adding your
own custom object is slightly more
complex but we will get through it so at
least for me I had a horrible time
trying to figure out how to do all this
there's a lot of like snippets of
documentation there's a like a couple of
sources that I found to be fairly useful
but I need a step-by-step so anyways
hopefully for all of you who need step
by steps as well this will save you a
ton of time so anyways let's go ahead
and get started I'm going to be doing
this on this paper space here if you
want to know more about paper space I'll
put a link in the description and also
there's a referral link there for ten
dollars of credit that'll be more than
enough to train your own custom object
for sure mainly I'm using it because my
GPUs are ocupado so I just don't have a
free GPU for this so anyways let's go
over like the brief steps for this
entire process and then we'll start with
the first steps so basically what you
need to do if you want to track a custom
object is you you could train a model
from scratch but I wouldn't recommend it
there's really no good reason that I can
think of that you would actually do that
so it's better to take a pre trained
model that is pre trained to Gen output
boxes basically around objects so with
the the tensorflow object detection API
they already have quite a few
pre-trained models you can kind of play
around with them and they basically
defer between it's a trade-off between
accuracy and speed now for my purposes I
want speed because I'm trying to do this
in real time so I'm gonna go with the
one that's the fastest but you can
change those if you want and when we get
to that point I'll show you your options
there but basically what you need is a
hundred one to five hundred images of
the object you want to track more image
the better but it gets very tedious to
like pull the images and you have to
hand label them and stuff and so anyways
some around that need those images
you've got to label the images and then
you're gonna split them into train and
test samples and then you're going to
generate ATF record for the train and
test split basically you'll set up a
configuration file you'll train an
actual model then once you're happy with
how how the training is going you'll
export that graph and then you can bring
in that basically the the frozen
inference graph and use that to classify
things as we did in part one in two so
to get started first you're gonna want
to grab like I was saying like a couple
hundred images so I guess we'll just use
Chrome it doesn't matter I mean I can't
think of a better password and then
passwords so yeah so then so like to
grab images you have a couple options I
you I would use like Google Images you
could use Bing images and then you could
use like image in it and that would be
like image net org why is this going so
slow we don't have time for this
let's try it this way
so so the object I'm going to track here
is like you know when you have powerful
technology like this you want to be able
to like change the world you know so you
want to do something that's super
meaningful so I thought that probably
the best thing is like you know what do
people have like a real problem with in
life and I thought that like being able
to find the macaroni and cheese was like
super important so macaroni and cheese
and if we search that weis is still
loaded ok whatever anyway you can go to
images and boom you got a lot of images
of the super essential ingredient to
life that is macaroni and cheese so at
this point you just start pulling these
images now I'm not gonna do them all I'm
just gonna grab like a couple just to
show you the process and then I'm gonna
do the rest off this process will take
at least for me every time I've done it
it takes you know maybe 2 hours I mean
it's a long long process so I'm not
gonna make you guys sit through for me
doing it because you're gonna have to do
it yourself anyway so what I'm just
going to do is I want to make a new
folder here and I just we call it images
and then I would just start dragging
these into the images folder so I'm take
that Wow
take this one and I'll take this one and
again you'd want to have you know I did
you do me like this con just not play
these games right now I really should've
been able to take those images I'm not
really sure why I did that to me maybe
because that was so huge that was those
looks like a pretty large image speaking
of which generally like I would look for
images that are about 800 wide 600 tall
but you kind of want to switch it up
like I wouldn't get all the same you
know 800 by 600 images I would try to
get a good mix of images so some that
are maybe portraits some that are
landscape so try to mix those up try to
mix up the sizes you just don't want
like an image that's really tiny and you
also don't really want why are these
coming through as links this is driving
me nuts is that really gonna be a link
to an image this these are clearly I
believe those are just images I just
don't know why this clong Italy
let me rename these so image 1 image -
it's like the 90th time I've done this
and this is I swear the first time I've
had this strange issue where they're
like like I feel like this arrow is like
it's linking to a thing and I don't want
that but I'm gonna go ahead and say that
the dot jpg means it's a it's an actual
image we'll see it's still not loading
thank you thank you so don't trust this
I don't trust this I feel like it's
still linking out it must be the
difference because I'm using Firefox
maybe it's Firefox it's specifically
doing this to me anyway okay I'm just
going to save it to images manually this
way if you use Chrome you really can't
I'm pretty sure just drag it like that's
what I've been doing so anyway we'll
just use this one
image and actually this one was okay and
I'm gonna close the sets with that
because that's getting irritating let's
see if chrome works now so once you have
all your images the next thing you're
gonna want to do is get a way to
annotate those images thank you sir so
I'm gonna use a program called label
image so label image and then follow
that with github because if you just
type a label image you're not going to
find it so come here to this github here
and this is basically the program we're
going to use you could either just clone
a door or whatever so in fact I'm just
gonna copy it this gives it the desktop
so get clone I'm gonna paste this in and
then once you have it you're gonna want
to install it as per their lovely
instructions down here and basically
once you open it up well it's done so
we'll go ahead and follow the
installation instructions now so we're
using Python 3 and tt5 so that's fine so
let's go ahead and just run these setup
steps
I'm guessing El XML is probably already
here hopefully this doesn't take too
long there we go
but let's just see if Alex Mauser yep
sorry there so then we'll just make UT 5
pi/3 oh we probably need to be in the
directory so change directory into
desktop probably label L really where
are you I thought we put it to this up
oh no we come on here soon let's see so
it would have been right there label
image so CD label image and then let's
do make okay and then finally using
Python 3 let's open label image pi boom
ok so then we get this nice beautiful
little GUI and then what you can do is
open a directory in this case we're only
gonna have one image but that's ok so
head to desktop images whoops
sorry just images and then you want to
open an entire directory normally you'll
have like a huge list here of all the
images and then it's like super quick to
just start iterating through them but
zoom in a little bit so now what you're
going to do is for every image you're
gonna create rec box basically like this
ok around the objects that you're trying
to track now you guys don't all have to
do macaroni and cheese if you want to I
can host the like a zip of all the
images and I'll put that in the
text-based tutorial so look in the
description if you want but I encourage
you to do your own object I mean it's
it's worth it just try to think of
something you really want to do and then
track your own objects but it's still a
tedious stuff and if you just wanna kind
of want to get your
just learn how it's done sure you can
just you can do my macaroni so anyways
when you draw your box once and one time
only you'll have to add like a label so
minds can be mac and cheese hit enter
and and then you'll put you'd want to
lay if there's multiples in the images
you'll want to label the other one as
well so again draw your bounding box and
then it should already say whatever the
last object was so you just hit enter
then ctrl s to save I would just save it
in the same directory save and then hit
next image and just some short keys
obviously ctrl s to save enter to pick
that thing that was the object and then
you can press W and that'll start the
the rect box for you so just an idea of
does speed things up I don't know if
there's a shortcut for next image but
that would be convenient too but
eventually you get a grab your mouse
anyways to draw the box so it's not a
big deal so anyways once you have your
images labeled because you're going to
basically hit next image and just do
this for we all somewhere between 100
and 500 images once you've done all that
you can go ahead to go to the next
tutorial again if you just want if you
just want to follow along with this
tutorial and not have to label all the
images you can use mine like I said I'll
put a link to the this part of the
tutorial in the description and the the
like a download link for all of them
I'll post on that page anyway that's it
for now if you have questions comments
concerns of whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you in
the next tutorial